we've got Prague Anish and Wesley here
to solve our puzzle of the day let's see
who gets it first and in how much time
why to play mate into
we've already got an answer
I was thinking between somebody say when
they eat it I like the sound of it I
like the sound of that movie I like the
sound of that yeah normally made into
you just have to make a quiet mode so
you have to look
you guys have to give me one answer
[Music]
each one there's 28
there's no discussion allowed yeah
can we get one position without Prague
interfering so
the problem is
coach wrote this uh puzzle box recently
so park knows all about it even before
huh
is Queen Aid your final answer Prague
yeah
yeah
everyone
we have a winner we have a
way to say I have to give it to Prague
he's the first one who said it Wesley so
we split the price
we'll speak to the chief habitat the
price for this no you can't you can't
defend the winner because you have the
same nationality so there's comments he
said it first
she's biased you don't know maybe I told
him no we haven't Prague with Queen Aid
in about 10 seconds if there is like a
rook here or something like this and
then you have all the pieces on the
diagonal and that would make it actually
prettier
no but there's probably some other yeah
it doesn't work now whatever you want
but I don't think it's gonna hit the
only movement
yeah but now it's very pretty because
now you've got all the pieces lined up
and the last piece comes in the diagonal
and it's over
there we have it set up another puzzle
competition and this one and each wins
what is my price
your price is
yeah you got your Puma shoes
good luck good well done Prague